Spider-Man or cat man it's not all Glitz
and glamor for our favorite web slinging
crime fighter sometimes even the biggest
stars find themselves in an awkward
situation these are the moments that
left our favorite Spider-Man actors
feeling embarrassed on the set of no way
home
number one better out than in drawing a
stunt in no way home Tom was attached to
both Zendaya and Jacob batalon as they
had to jump off scaffolding together
when they landed Tom accidentally let
one rip it's tough the suit's tight the
harness squeezes it squeezes your
intestines Zendaya was sitting on Tom's
leg when it happened so she didn't just
hear it I felt the rattle that is always
an awkward situation and Tom definitely
got the worst of it unfortunately
because the suit is so tight I could
smell everything for the rest of the day
it seems that they now enjoy the memory
of that embarrassing moment that's a
good one good times number two nothing
is more embarrassing than not getting an
I love you back Andrew Garfield telling
the other two Spider-Man I love you guys
was an improvised moment and the
reactions of Toby Maguire and Tom
Holland are genuine reactions to this
unprompted line they just awkwardly
stared back at Andrew who had to settle
for a thank you yikes the film makers
love this moment so much that they
worked it into the movie and when they
tried to get more takes of it all they
got instead was a bunch of laughter
you're kidding me
yes I'm not
number three who's the superhero here
I'm the superhero I'm supposed to look
cool normally Spider-Man is the one
saving the day and catching MJ but
behind the scenes the roles were
reversed Zendaya said because of their
height difference the actress would land
before Tom and Tom's feet would swing
out from underneath him and Zendaya
would catch him let's save me MJ even
though it can be embarrassing to be
caught by the person you're supposed to
be catching Tom did appreciate the
change of roles so nice to be caught for
a change number four why was there so
much slipping on this set the sanctum
sanctorum was covered in snow for the
movie and the crew used practical fake
snow to achieve this effect but it had
the unintended consequence of being very
slippery everyone seemed to be unable to
get their footing and slipping on the
fake snow was running rampant Benedict
Cumberbatch couldn't get his footing
after floating down the stairs having to
do multiple takes and Tom let out a
bunch of expletives after slipping on
the stuff sorry
the filmmakers took it in stride though
as the embarrassing moment can be seen
in the final movie number five what in
the world is going on here Peter and
MJ's video call had a lot more laughing
going on behind the scenes Tom couldn't
stop goofing around making meow sounds
inconstant me laughing little did Tom
know that the camera crew was rolling
the entire time and Tom couldn't hide
his embarrassment when he found out his
Antics had been caught on camera even
rolling this on time
number six sometimes it's the little
things we all know the feeling of not
being able to hold back our laughter and
when that happens just looking at
someone can make you laugh there was an
awkward scene between Tobey Maguire and
Andrew Garfield where the duo had to
look at each other for a long time
without saying anything and things got
uncomfortable it is weird staring at you
for that long number seven who knew
Peter Parker was so clumsy Spider-Man
may have great balance but Tom Holland
not so much Tom was slipping and sliding
all around set even knocking over an
entire dresser at one point and during
his intense fight scene with the Green
Goblin Tom slipped and ended up flat on
the ground but he recovered nicely by
striking a pose what's weird is that Tom
is very athletic and agile so why does
he trip up so much
number eight brothers will be brothers
you may not know that Tom's brother
Harry was actually going to appear in no
way home he had a scene where he was a
robber that was stopped by Tom Holland
Spider-Man to shoot the scene he had to
hang upside down for a very long period
of time Tom joked about doing the upside
down kiss with him while he was dangling
in front of everyone but the most
embarrassing part is that the scene was
ultimately cut from the film even though
Harry was really excited to be in the
movie he said to me he goes you know
mate it was really tough but I was just
really excited about being in a
Spider-Man movie fortunately we do get
to see this scene in the more fun stuff
Extended Cut number nine Charlie Cox
says Daredevil is back however Charlie
was initially unsure if appearing in no
way home would be a good idea he thought
his run as the character was completely
over and thought Kevin feige was joking
at first when he realized the offer was
real you know being given the
opportunity to Place someone who has a
disability but he started to feel
embarrassed before he even got to set
and when he did arrive he was very
intimidated he wasn't sure if his return
would land with audiences and while most
theaters in America cheered when he
appeared his worst fear was realized in
the theater he went to I must have been
one of the only movie cases in America
that had was dead silence number 10. it
looks great on screen but in real life
the Spider-Man suit has many drawbacks
but some of the most embarrassing ones
are the Aesthetics Tom Holland's mask is
unflattering when it doesn't have a
helmet piece to hold it up it just kind
of collapses on itself so it looks
really
interesting to say the least not only
that but it accentuates Tom's head shape
which he wasn't too happy about USA
really are able to see how strange my
head shape the cherry on top of all of
it is that the suit looks awkward in
specific places it makes you look small
in all areas where you don't want to
look small
number 11 sometimes things just don't
translate well Alfred Molina kept
improvising a joke about being fixed
like a dog unfortunately Tom didn't
understand the reference because in the
UK they don't use the term fixing for
dogs why does he keep ad-living things
lying about fixing dogs Tom made it
known that he was confused about what
the saying meant and kept responding to
Molina honestly and I kept responding
with like no why would you fix a dog
number 12. we've done our research and
we still can't figure out who it is Tom
Holland revealed that there was one
Spider-Man actor who was hiding a little
extra something under their suit one of
us has a fake ass in their suit Holland
didn't give away who though and neither
did Andrew Garfield who just laughed at
Tom's confession he's just staring the
pot old Tom he can't help himself
whoever it is must be embarrassed if
they're keeping it a secret but we see
no problem with a little extra boost in
the back
number 13 get a grip Spidey Andrew
Garfield couldn't get a hold of his mask
during the scene when he meets Ned and
MJ in an embarrassing moment for
Garfield he dropped his mask and then
when he tried to retrieve it couldn't
bend down to grab it because the wires
he was attached to were holding him back
so he did what Spider-Man would do and
gave up whatever one of the crew members
then swooped in to save the day we get
secondhand embarrassment just watching
these moments luckily for the actors
with a little editing magic all we see
as the audience are their good moments
but it's fun to to get this little peek
behind the curtain which moment did you
find most embarrassing let us know in
the comments and thanks for stopping by
at the things